welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode 2 which does not bode well for
our future well that of the sacred
timeline or our own coming environmental
doom the extinction of swallows are you
kidding me we couldn't save the birds as
always there were so many hard to spot
details hidden throughout this episode
so i'm gonna break it down shot by shot
for everything you might have missed
support this channel by checking out our
new loki inspired merch options like the
awesome shirt loki out of time you can
get this at new
we open on a renaissance fair in oshkosh
wisconsin 1985 the year time travel
fiction really climbed to new popularity
with the release of back to the future
notice how as the dates swipe back to
that it looks like the first to swipe
past is 2023 telling us that the tva
frame of reference for us is the current
mcu present year of 2024. hunter c20
tracks the loki variant to this green
tent with a golden sign out front for a
miniature pony green and gold of course
being loki's colors but also
coincidentally crossing in front of the
temp ad is this blonde woman doesn't
look like sophia dimartino but they are
looking for someone who looks like loki
when they really should be looking for
someone who looks like that so this
episode ultimately reveals the variant
to be a female played by sophia
dimartino perhaps lady loki from the
comics which is a reincarnation of
loki's soul in a new female body though
if you look closely to alternate
language dubs in the credits she is
credited as sylvie which could be for
sylvie lushton aka enchantress sylvia is
a girl in broxton oklahoma when the
asgardians relocate there and that same
run in the comics she wakes up with
powers and it's later suggested she
might have been wholly created by loki
as a kind of joke i suspect this show
might be combining elements of sylvie
with lady loki but since this show for
now considers her to be a loki variant
i'm just gonna call her lady loki here
bonnie tyler's 1984 song holding out for
a hero is queued up with a recording
[Music]
hold on did lady loki take the time to
audio edit a recording so that it
transitioned on holding out for a hero
or was holding out for a hero already
the music this 1985 renfair had queued
up either way this is some real joker
[ __ ] that tells us this lady loki has a
flare for the dramatic and is willing to
take her time tinkering with electronics
and the prize being the princess sets up
our loki as the hero we're holding out
for chasing his princess oh wow i think
the evil is actually something else that
could prevail lady lucky pairs her
consciousness with c20 wanda maximoff's
illusion curses a similar look to this
with the eyes lighting up but here the
spell is mind control something loki
previously could only do with the mind
stone in the scepter but we will soon
learn from mobius that variant loki's
have different powers the close-up of
the temp pad shows icons for time door
and miss minutes again miss minutes is a
selectable function as she is on the
elevator maybe at any given moment they
can unleash her as a weapon or kind of
sound an alarm speaking of whom loki
asks if miss minutes is a recording or
if she's alive are you recording or are
you alive uh sort of bows yeah he tries
to swat her and the fact that miss
minutes goes to the effort of dodging
these confirms she exists in the real
world reacting moment to moment and you
can hear her shoes making noises
watch it where's your manners
oh hey quit it
that is not nice and at one point she
stands on the hourglass which remember
is the symbol at the heart of the tva
logo maybe showing that she could have
some authority over the tva like i
theorized she might be linked with the
timekeepers kind of the way the cree
supreme intelligence is a reactive ai
that controls that society now on the
screen is a multiple choice question
thanos has two apples he eats both but
realizes he wants more he goes back in
time 20 minutes and eats the apples
again does this mean the apples will not
have existed in the timeline he left a
no because time is constantly happening
b the question doesn't matter because a
branch cannot change another time branch
or c thanos would have been hungry prior
because the grandfather paradox already
accounted for the change in matter
before its move i love it all three
options are explanations we have heard
in time travel fiction before like a
being our approach time is just always
happening c being our this always
happened approach in which things are
what they are meant to be in the future
and b being the correct answer within
loki's logical framework in which branch
timelines cannot affect other branch
timelines they each play out in real
time independently this is actually the
point mobius later corrects loki on at
the fair and loki didn't know because
he's slacking off here and i love how it
uses rewinding apples the example doctor
strange used to display time travel and
reminds us that thanos died hungry
also shows that the tva knows who thanos
is and apparently considered his
genocide just part of the sacred
timeline mobius shows some other loki
variants including a blue one remember
loki's natural frost giant form is blue
skin he's very an l1247 but when you
punch up to close up it changes to 6792
and variant l1247 shows loki as a
cyclist having won the tour de france
then a beastly loki who appears to be
l6792 a bearded loki l 8914 with natural
black horns and then a loki with a more
traditional viking armor l7803 mobius
says each loki has a different power set
but all of them seem to have the power
of illusion projection though loki
corrects him saying that there's a
distinction between illusion projection
and duplication casting illusion
projection being like when loki
projected shape-shifted forms of cap and
odin over himself or when he projected
thor's severed arm in the dark world
meanwhile duplication casting being
anytime loki tricked other people with
alternate doubles of himself but this
clarification of loki's power set helps
set up loki's sorcery as far more
diverse than we realized for example him
using telekinesis to summon a roomba in
that rocks cart fight something i don't
think we had ever previously seen him do
in the wren fair loki's talky talky
talking doesn't work on mobius and the
others they end up using a reset charge
on the tent this time giving us a
close-up of it it looks like the main
chamber containing this orange fluid but
then the charge releases an upper
chamber of purple fluid that mixes until
it reaches a saturation point that
releases this rainbowy puddle that
resets everything within the radius it's
almost like these are made of specific
amounts of matter and antimatter that
mix together and that collision undo's
the fabric of the nearby reality and as
we see this branch pruned on the chrome
monitor screen other past branch
locations tick past including ninja
velir that's the armory realm where thor
met eitri an acquired stormbreaker in
infinity war and sakar that's the trash
planet of the ragnarok where loki thor
banner and valkyrie escaped so even
though it seemed like the tva was
earth-specific from the animation last
episode they actually oversee all the
planets in the known mcu universe
rensselaer's office has the statue of
timekeeper asked centered right behind
her seat just like in the courtroom and
just like in the final shot of the end
credits we now begin in close up on this
one also notice that zorth and vanth are
holding hourglasses but ast's arms are
outstretched in kind of a saintly pose
mobius even begins to say something
about the odd one out but renslayer cuts
him off although i shouldn't say that
that one looks like he's got the
timekeepers i'm monitoring every aspect
of this case yeah i think these are more
clues that this timekeeper in particular
might have a special relationship with
red slayer mobius points out other
mission trophy artifacts like a snow
globe and you can later see it read san
diego rensselaer says you're not the
only analyst working for me yeah mobius
brings up this other analyst a few times
including this pen from franklin d
roosevelt high school i don't remember
this this must be from that analyst you
keep on the side yeah mobius seems a bit
jealous of this mystery analyst so let's
all keep an eye out for some other
analysts that might be in the shadows
notice how mobius does not use a coaster
leaving more ring stains on that table
the end credits actually show a ring
stain on his chrono monitor handbook so
here's another possible clue like maybe
the reason mobius doesn't remember
leaving these ring stains is because
this other analyst is a variant of him
and just like loki is one of many loki's
in a box so is mobius he could be
arriving at his own future existential
crisis notice how rensselaer signs a
report r slayer a little tease showing
us she's not afraid to get her hands
dirty and moby assigns mmm since his
full name is mobius m mobius and i love
the hallways labyrinthian design like
notice the third quarter is the same set
as the first one that they walked down
like the set designers just doubled it
up maybe as a way to make loki seem lost
and helpless in the tva now the
elevator's descent was shot in the real
life atlanta marriott marquis but as the
camera tilts down you can see how they
actually recomposited the lower levels
with those big timekeeper statues in the
bookshelves of the tva archives loki
reads a report talking about the
variance destruction of central
california oil fields if you look
closely this would be another oil field
that she destroyed after that one in
oklahoma last episode maybe she
genuinely is trying to reverse the
impact of climate change in the
background of this library setting you
can actually see the floors behind loki
reading syf
2 w 1 all of these correspond to floors
in the elevator but one of them is 372
which could be a nod to thor 372 which
is the first comic appearance of the
timekeepers the librarian shuts loki
down saying the creation of the tva the
beginning of time the end of time these
are all classified just another sign
that tva narrative commission's video
about the history of timekeepers may or
may not be the full story so loki reads
the report on the destruction of asgard
as we saw in thor ragnarok listed here
is a class seven apocalypse total
planetary destruction
9719 deaths which would be the entire
civilization minus the refugees who
escaped on the statesman and you could
also see code name revengers which is
the team name that thor improvised to
valkyrie and ragnarok has it got a name
it's a yeah it's called the
revenges revenges because i'm getting
revenge
you're getting revenge and you're you
you what are you you want revenge i um
and i'm just undecided but before i
continue thanks to blue blocks for
sponsoring this video see a long day of
staring at screens can be really tough
on your eyes on particularly screen
intense days i notice my eyes start to
feel heavy i start to have problems
sleeping blue light damages our eyes and
leads to digital eye strain symptoms of
digital eye strain include blurred
vision headaches and dry watery eyes for
some folks this could even affect your
energy level well
blue blocks was created to fix this
problem and block out blue light with
high quality lenses blue blocks are
evidence-backed and made under optics
laboratory conditions in australia they
have over 40 styles of frames and come
in prescription non-prescription and
readers so they have frames for every
need go to blueblocks.com newrockstars
or click the link below and you will get
20 off your order and get free shipping
worldwide on orders over 115 dollars so
get your energy back sleep better and
block out the unhealthy effects of blue
light with blue blocks that's b l u b l
o x com new rockstars or just click the
link below code automatically applied at
checkout for 20 off also from now until
june 30th blue box is having a special
end of the financial year sale where you
can get 25 off any orders over 160
dollars and save 30 off any order over
315 and thanks again to blue box for
sponsoring this video so loki deduces
from lack of variance energy detected
that their killer must be hiding in
historical apocalypses which end those
societies anyway creating this example
of ruining mobius's salad and stealing
casey's boku fruit juice kind of like
josta another beverage from the 90s that
you cannot get anymore he also mentions
maybe pushing hulk off the rainbow
bridge which bruce branner very nearly
does during that final battle
loki's mind may also go to that because
hulk having to descend the stairs was
what led to tony fumbling the tesseract
and allowing loki to escape in a branch
timeline loki brings up other possible
apocalyptic events it could be a tidal
wave it could be a meteor it could be a
volcano a supernova yeah we actually see
two of those huge waves from the
hurricane the volcano mount vesuvius so
we may also see a meteor in a supernova
as upcoming apocalypses on the show like
that interplanetary calamity teased in
trailer footage so they visit the
destruction of pompei in 79 a.d you
actually see it written in roman
numerals on the wall there as well here
loki tests creating chaos by releasing
these goats be free my own friends be
free yeah lugi calls them his horned
friends referencing his own horns the
horns of all variant loki's may be
foreshadowing the way he will let other
horned friends go free mobius talks
about his love of jet skis in the early
1990s for a brief shining moment there
was a beautiful union
of form and function which we call the
jet ski as a floridian can confirm jet
skis our peak form of transportation
like you can imagine a rule confined tva
agent must love the idea of a solo
piloted craft where you can wander
freely without any speed limits or
traffic lines you have to stay within if
we don't see this man on a jetski by the
end of this series we will riot they
debate the comparative absurdity of
their origin stories timekeeper space
lizards vs norse mythology and it's real
because i believe it's real actually
later marvel comics linked the asgardian
mythology with the celestials by saying
asgardians are aliens in a certain
celestial mutation cycle in which the
beliefs of those they protect map onto
them in this case the norse people of
midgard mobius explains that the tva
protects what came before while the
timekeepers untangle the sacred
timeline's epilogue from its infinite
branches and that once they're finished
no more nexus events just order and we
meet in peace at the end of time this
would mean that nexus events are
accidents that only occur because the
sacred timeline isn't yet woven tightly
enough by the time keepers so they
dictate which random strands need to be
clipped in order to make the rope that
stretches endlessly into the future
perfectly tight and once that process is
complete then they all meet at the end
of all time mobius remembers that
kablooey gum from episode one candy
have candy on asgard yeah grapes nuts
i wonder you're so bitter actually
remember when loki posed as odon asgard
he snacked on grapes while watching that
play since that gum was only sold on
earth from 2047 to 2051 they look at
various disasters like the climate
disaster of 2048 the tsunami of 2051 the
2050 extinction of the swallow and the
2049 eruption of krakatoa which is a
volcanic island in indonesia that
erupted in 1883 and apparently will
erupt again yeah quite a bleak picture
for earth in the coming 30 years can't
wait but they zero in on the rox cart
disaster class 10 apocalypse when a
category 8 hurricane hit haven hills
alabama in 2050. now the report says
entire town annihilated 10 835 humans
dead but planetary body intact meaning
there are worse calamities coming where
the planet will be destroyed with a
reference to another case file
presumably describing when that happens
now category 8 hurricane is just
depressing since the scale really only
goes up to category 5 meaning future
meteorologists must adjust the scale for
increasingly powerful storms due to the
rise of global ocean temperatures now
rox cart with the two x's is an odd to
roxanne that's the energy conglomerate
of marvel comics that has shown up in
the background of iron man movies in the
future they apparently build an entire
company town with massive costco style
superstores because why not branch out
into retail right by the way another
marvel corporation advanced idea
mechanics aim from iron man 3 actually
made a little cameo in episode 1 as the
maker of that shovel from the year 22-22
so muppies gives loki back his daggers
which hunter b-15 immediately
confiscates i love that since the camera
follows them into the locker room
without cutting they have to time
wounmi's entrance perfectly so that
she'll be right there to snatch them a
second later i just love when you can
see the effort the actors and the
director go into good old-fashioned
comedic timing just via blocking so
haven hills 2050 is revealed with this
electronic billboard of the peaceful
seaside town with rocks on smokestacks
polluting the sky which of course leads
to the climate disaster that's now
consuming it so that this billboard
blows down revealing its true status
right behind before and after beachfront
now washed way in tons of flooding
structures collapsing buildings
exploding this has got to be my favorite
disaster imagery of any marvel title i
can think of because it's not at all
caused by invading alien threats or
robots run amok it's just humanity over
time it also neatly reflects this series
production design of futuristic elements
being destructive and toxic and crappy
while the retro design of the tva seems
perpetual ironclad clean i also love the
little design details they put into the
2050 roxcart store like holographic
greeter in the parking lot this rolling
helper robot employee badges that light
up reading welcome can i help you also
in the break room there is a poster
reading a great place to work a great
place to shop everything you need for
happiness yikes that shopper is buying
azaleas because of a hurricane sale
meaning that these must be common enough
that roxcart schedules sales events
around them but this guy turns out to be
a lady loki drone and he transfers his
consciousness to b15 and then to that
employee randy and then finally to this
hoss and like c20 b15 wakes up from lady
loki's possession shivering coming back
from some curse that rattled her to her
core c20 reveals that she told lady loki
where the timekeepers are meaning that
they are probably the true target of
this sacred timeline bombing and finally
the villain reveals her
[Music]
face isn't about you
so it is confirmed sophia di martino is
playing a female loki variant most
likely lady loki now in the comics lady
loki is not really an alternate timeline
variant but loki's disembodied soul
after ragnarok reincarnated into a
female body however that still might be
the case here since this loki can
transfer her soul into new bodies she
may just be a human female that loki's
soul decided to stay in but also notice
that one of the horns on her crown is
broken off could be a nod to loki's
looking agent of asgard or a reflection
of how she might not consider herself a
true loki the way she told loki not to
call her that she may be someone with a
loki style curse but go by silly also
she might be telepathic because as she
reveals herself listen closely you can
hear tom hiddleston's voice echoing in
there
what is this about
this isn't about you
yeah making her words here a response to
loki's thoughts so using stolen reset
charges and stolen temp pads she bombs
the sacred timeline creating branches
throughout time and space rinselayer's
screen actually shows a lot of the dates
and locations we gotta break these down
actually first in the chrome monitor
room you can see nowhere that's a
severed celestial head location in the
guardians of the galaxy and then
barcelona and then below niftleheim
that's the asgardian realm that hella
was believed to be exiled in and then
dartford england but then onto
rinslayer's screen you see august 3rd
1522 fong naw vietnam march 31st 1492
lisbon portugal perhaps something
related to columbus's atlantic voyage
that year april 23 2301 vormir vermeer's
a resting place of the soul stone seen
in infinity war and end game april 23rd
was infinity war's release date in 2018.
october 25th 1551 thornton colorado
november 22nd 1999 cookeville tennessee
and then february 16 2004 asgard so the
home of loki and thor eight years or so
prior to the events of the first thor
film october 3rd 1390 rome italy i'm
assuming some kind of vatican drama
there august 13 1984 sakar teo so again
zakar from thor ragnarok tayo's the name
of its star system 1984 could have been
during the reign of one of those past
arena champions that we saw on the
outside of the building february 2nd
1808 maricara colombia july 17 1700
purvu finland december 17th 1382
ego as in ego the living planet showing
that yeah this guy was planting seeds
around the galaxy for over 700 years
before he met peter's mother october
13th 1982 titan titan of course the
planet thanos grew up on and the ruins
of which he fought the avengers upon an
infinity war 1982 could have been around
when titan came upon environmental ruin
that set thanos on his mission september
21st 1947 new york new york i was
thinking cap's return date and end game
but i think that was confirmed to be
1948. march 1st 1984 tokyo january 3rd
51 a.d holla holla is the cree home
world seen in captain marvel they
reached peak evolution years before
humanity did so this could be right in
the midst of their advanced races
history august 2nd 1999 kingsport
tennessee september 24th 1001 zandar now
zandar is the home to the nova corps
seen in guardians of the galaxy november
23rd 2005 beijing july 18th 1903 madrid
and then above the time doors you could
also see portland in 2004 and jutenheim
gotenheim is loki's home realm land of
the frost giants now i plan to dig more
into each of these dates and locations
because i think lady loki might have
targeted each of these specifically to
alter history so i'll be digging that in
a separate video coming out tomorrow we
end with ranslayer grabbing her staff
likely realizing that the variant's real
plan is to flush out tva agents leaving
it undefended so that she can get to the
timekeepers that's probably where lady
loki is headed now with loki close
behind either to stop her or to join her
but in either case not according to the
script of the sacred timeline follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstar subscribe to rockstars for
everything loki thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you